hello everyone my name is the volgen and
you're watching skip rewind the show
that is basically a recap of my videos
that you may have missed and then some
SCP biz news or noteworthy things that I
want to share with everyone so first of
all let's go through the videos that you
may have missed the first one is SCP 31
what is love hull of a SCP zai cover in
these I don't really want to spoil any
of it but this is kind of funny
I'm kind of disturbing at the same time
it's based on love let's just say that
the second one is SCP 426 I am a toaster
this is a really classic one this is one
of the first ones I ever read about five
or six years ago so it has a special
place in my heart if you haven't heard
of it I can't imagine you you haven't
heard of it but if you haven't go and
watch this video it's a very creative
SCP it's not just a standard monster
kind of thing the third one is sep11 67
disembodied robot head fun fact about
this it got demonetised for three days
because it had the word disembodied head
in the title so yeah that was fun but
it's pretty interesting I always kind of
liked robot or sci-fi beast scps
so if you're like me you're definitely
going to want to check this one right
the fourth one you probably have seen
because this video did particularly well
SCP 1936 ill port this is a Cthulhu
Mythos based SCP which i think is why it
did so well I'm really happy with how it
turned out it's one of the ones I'm most
proud of so if by any chance you haven't
seen it go and watch it because I have
the SCP that I've done this year it's
probably the one that I'm most proud of
and finally SCP 32 nine board and
butterfly I really liked this one it has
a really good ending it's like kind of a
twist ending bright Twilight Zone style
handin which I really like it's not
often you see SCP documents with twist
and ins this is a document that kind of
reads like a teal I'm actually thinking
of making researcher Miller given him
some anomalous properties or he has
Gihon some anomalous properties that
allows him to touch an object and get an
idea of the emotion that the person that
held it did it would give me more of an
opportunity to actually do voice acting
in these tales so for example if if a
researcher Miller picks up a piece of
paper the person that wrote the note on
that piece of paper he will be able to
sense the emotion or something if you
have any ideas for that kind of thing I
would really like to have like a common
explanation for it I think that's a good
step forward for the researcher Miller
character if I develop lore around my
document reads I think it makes it a wee
bit more interesting for people so if
you have any ideas on how I could any
universe justifying research or Miller
feeling or experience in what that
person experienced let me know because I
want to try and incorporate more voice
acting in character anyway moving on
those are the document videos that I've
done if any of them sound good I keep on
repeating myself put watch them if you'd
like I know I'm gonna move on to some
news
the first one I just really I really
want to get this sight first because
it's really important if at any stage
you want to write an SCP I get asked for
some reason I've never written anything
I'm really bad at writing but a lot of
people ask me do you have any tips for
writing an SCP no I don't have any of
those tips but dr. Sumerian has created
an entire episode of a podcast on it you
really need to check this out it's
incredibly interesting I I watched it
even though I have really new skills for
for writin SCPs
but he goes through a lot of things in
the video there that make you think
about what you're doing about accepting
criticism all that kind of stuff of
course the the links to this video will
be in the description please watch it if
you know anybody else that could benefit
from it I know there is so many people
that could benefit from it at the time
of recording it only has about 300 views
which is criminal as far as I'm
concerned so if you know any aspiring
authors if you're an aspiring author
what's this video it's about 23 minutes
long you will not regret listening to
this next up is a movie poster for a
fictional SCP movie IRA well like this
is existed for quite a while I can't
actually find the original artist but
it's a pretty cool looking poster the
most interesting thing about this post
on Reddit was by ratah easer
agent macleod with my Clio SCP and he
has the best response to this post and
this is why I'm including it he said
pray rommel disclaimers this poster is
[ __ ] wicked I'm pretty sure that's
Gear's proposal regardless Jiji creator
number 2 this is gonna be a bit of a
long ramble it wasn't that long but
anyway okay so a foundation fell on my
top tation whether a feature length or a
series or a miniseries or what havi is
bar none
one of my favorite things to talk about
the topic pops up on the main wiki's
forums a lot
I'm 90% positive what I'm about to say
has already been said before but here it
goes number one because of the Creative
Commons license a properly funded
foundation adaptation is highly unlikely
our license has been both a blessing and
a curse number two we're not a single
genre writing community we're heavily
associated with horror because we
started as a creepypasta community but
we are not just horror there is comedy
both in the classic sense and the
colloquial sense there is tragedy there
is horror there is fantasy there is
sci-fi both of the soft on hard variety
there is mystery there's a ton of
different genres all created in the SCP
form Oh number three the flexible multi
common thing we've got going on you may
know this batter as their friend
quote there is no common wood absolutely
play into an SCP film adaptation either
and it played with its own rules
and not be internally consistent or most
likely it take a lot of artistic license
with everything it directly adopts from
the wiki look at Lord bongs confinement
series for an example of what I'm
talking about with this in mind this is
what I personally like to see in an SCP
film adaptation and all of this I agree
with by the way number one a large
ensemble cast there be nuclear
protagonist and maybe not even a clear
antagonist unless a villainous SCP like
106 were invoked a focus on all the
moving pieces of the foundation from
discovery to recovery from containment
to explanation neutralization on
disposal or release the foundation has a
lot going on and I'd like to see how a
filmmaker explains hi this massive extra
governmental conspiracy stays secret and
stays funded something akin to American
horror stories format instead of
focusing on a single site or somesuch
why not move it around for the
foundation I'd want it to feel less like
stargate sg1 or sanctuary and more like
The Twilight Zone though perhaps without
a rod sterling standin that right there
the twilight zone is the perfect
parallel for an SCP movie
so my ideal foundation allocation would
look like this a television series
without a constant cast each 30-minute
episode would focus on a small cast of
characters dealing with a single
incident or conflict a season could
showcase one SCP and all the people
connected to it or it could showcase one
research wing of one site or something
like that
business MOOCs who died in episode 1 of
a given season are the subject of
absolute three whether their story prior
to becoming SCP chyre or whatever is
explained a background conversation in
absolute - turned to be the center of
the plot in episode 9 some dude who's
been chilling in the background of every
episode is revealed to be nobody or no
five doing some Undercover Boss yet or
something the comic relief of one
episode is the background researcher
turned SCP of the next viewers will have
to connect the dots to make a full
picture out of everything just like the
readers on the SCP wiki actually do so
again that was by reddit user agent
McLeod SCP I hope I'm saying that right
I just don't know
see ya who essentially encapsulates
exactly what I want from an SCP
based series and also includes that's a
pipe dream essentially because of the
license of their CP 4 edition anyway I
thought it was cool the next thing is a
cosplay but I thought it was pretty
funny and it's a 426 that I've done a
video on a few weeks ago and that's just
the best cosplay ever have nothing else
to say just look at it
apologies for the length of this episode
but I'm gonna cut it off here thank you
very much for listening and I'll see you
all very soon
ok bye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gaza berry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you